cuántas veces hemos querido cambiar el
mundo
tenemos la ilusión por unos segundos de
que las cosas sean diferentes
pero después llega la razón que nos da
una serie de explicaciones para
arrancarnos esa idea de poder cambiar
algo en nuestro entorno y llevarnos a lo
que es más sencillo los imposibles
no se puede esto lleva años así
que podría ser yo para cambiar lo que
diferencia voy a hacer
por donde podría empezar
esto que nos limita a nuestra única
realidad y nos deja en las buenas
intenciones o como bien decimos la
intención es lo que cuenta
y no por complicado que parezca y aunque
la mayoría de las veces nos quedemos en
este proceso existe un momento en el que
logramos vencer el pesimismo cuando nos
convencemos de que somos capaces nos
comprometemos a buscar el cómo y el
cuándo
y cuando los motivos son más grandes que
los pretextos y los miedos
para mí el motivo más grande que primero
me hace querer cambiarme y después
cambiar mi entorno se presenta en el
momento en el que me doy cuenta que
callar para no sentirme víctima no solo
me hacía daño a mí
el callar una agresión hace que
muchísimas mujeres experimenten lo que
por poco a mí me aleja de mis sueños
el callarnos a las mujeres nos trunca
caminos no nos deja crecer
profesionalmente y nos hace retroceder
les platico un poco de cómo llegué a mi
motivo cuando terminé la carrera me
decido a empezar mi vida laboral y como
me encantan los retos me metí a un mundo
donde desde el primer instante pude ver
que mis capacidades no eran valoradas
primero por ser mujer segundo por mi
edad y mi falta de experiencia y tercero
por mi físico
ay no ella es bonita no es capaz no es
inteligente es una muñequita de aparador
el mundo de los hombres y el poder
lo más fácil hubiera sido convencerme de
que no se podía para que intentar si ya
veía cuál sería el resultado
pero mi deseo era tan grande que decidí
quedarme
desde los primeros días recibí
insinuaciones y comentarios sexuales que
me incomodaban pero me acuerdo que a mis
23 años pensaba y que podía hacer yo
para evitar los salir corriendo
esto para mí jamás ha sido una opción ya
me caí aunque me cuesta aceptarlo me
convencí que era una buena oportunidad y
decidí aguantarme
segi y con el paso de los años las cosas
no cambiaron el acoso seguía aumentando
se sentían con derecho porque al final
no iba a pasarles nada
se protegen entre ellos se protegen con
su poder
hasta que en una ocasión después de una
campaña exitosa me citaron en las
oficinas presidenciales salté me gustó
porque había sido tomada en cuenta
se imaginan esa emoción después de todo
este sacrificio todo ese esfuerzo me
mandaron llamar
el hombre me recibió con una sonrisa que
tampoco voy a olvidar
me dijo que esta era una gran
oportunidad para mí me enseñó sus
oficinas me llevó hacia una puerta y
detrás de esta puerta una cama
me vi a los ojos y me dijo
solo esto tienes que pagar
por fin lo lograron me rompieron
estando ahí sentí muchísimo miedo
al salir sentí enojo frustración coraje
impotencia seguida de muchísimo asco
en mi mente solo pensaba que al hablar o
denunciar la única que saldría perdiendo
sería yo
así que como muchas mujeres en este país
preferí mi seguridad antes que mi
desarrollo y me fui
como era de esperarse yo fui la única
que salió perdiendo yo fui la que se fue
la que dejó esos años de infierno
también fui la que no triunfó
pero la verdad es que aprendí tanto que
al día de hoy no me arrepiento
hoy veo esta experiencia y tengo dos
sensaciones la positiva y la negativa
del lado positivo está la gran
satisfacción de haberlo intentado
de abandonar mis comodidades superar el
miedo a lo desconocido y luchar por mis
sueños y todo aquello que me motiva
también siento orgullo por haber
valorado mi esencia
por decidir mantener mi dignidad y no
cambiarla o cambiarla por absolutamente
nada
se me ofreció una gran oportunidad
laboral tal vez un mejor puesto o ganar
más
como si acostarme con alguien fuera más
fácil que seguir luchando
y déjenme aclarar algo cuando hablo de
dignidad no lo digo como una limitante
de mi sexualidad
yo hago con mi cuerpo lo que mis deseos
e instintos me manden
pero jamás dejaría que alguien utilice
mi cuerpo como utilizo en el poder
en lo negativo me frustra la ignorancia
y lo cobarde que fui al quedarme callada
nunca hablé de lo que me hacían
y cuando salí huyendo no encontré la
fuerza para denunciar porque para mí
sentirme vulnerable o ser víctima era un
golpe muy duro de realidad
además a las pocas personas que les
platiqué tanto en el trabajo como a mis
amigas y amigos
me decían con ironía y tú que esperabas
si así es él así son ellos todos dentro
de la política y fuera aquí hay que
aguantar porque no hay de otra
reacciones como esas me llevaron
a cosas equivocadas pensaba que tal vez
podía vivir con eso que no era para
tanto
que estaba exagerando
o hasta justificarlo diciendo bueno tan
siquiera no me toco
hoy
bueno que ahora que lo pienso no sé si
hubiera tenido tanta suerte de haberme
quedado en los pinos de ese día
hoy soy capaz de entender y me dedico
todos los días a transmitir que la
violencia a la que nos enfrentamos las
mujeres a lo largo de nuestra vida nos
va marcando por generaciones y que el
silencio que guardamos sobre ello nos ha
hecho muchísimo daño al grado
que 11 mujeres son asesinadas todos los
días en este país a causa de la
violencia de género
en el mundo la onu reportó que desde los
87 mil mujeres víctimas de homicidio
doloso en el 2018 el 58 por ciento fue a
manos de alguien en el que confiaban
padres hermanos tíos primos hijos
parejas
en méxico cuatro de cada diez mujeres
mayores a 18 años ha sufrido violencia
sexual la mayoría de ellas en sus casas
y no entendemos
seguimos con el silencio pues el 99.7 de
las mujeres que han sufrido violencia
sexual no denuncian
el 99.7 que significa agresores libres
impunes y más víctimas
lo lamentable y triste de la situación
es que aunque veamos la realidad se
siguen replicando comentarios de odio
que minimizan el dolor porque desean con
tanta fuerza que nada de esto cambia
me he preguntado si es por miedo a la
igualdad algo que no conocen y tal vez
ni se imaginan
si es por conservar privilegios a los
que están acostumbrados
pero cuando es una mujer la que me
cuestiona me señala y hasta agrede por
pensar diferente ahí mi panorama cambia
y ya no es tan sencillo
con una mujer no veo el privilegio que
desean conservar
tampoco los motivos lógicos por los que
no querrían tener el pleno acceso a sus
derechos en igualdad de condiciones
por qué no buscar derribar esas barreras
ideológicas que nos limitan nos
encasillan nos juzgan y nos cosifican
además de ignorar los motivos por los
que luchamos y los objetivos a las
mujeres nunca se nos inculcaron las
complicidades
desde chicas desde nuestras casas nos
transmitieron cómo debíamos de ser
sé bonita
y recatada sé amable se cuidadosa de
bonita
también se nos transmitió que debíamos
de hacer y a quién debíamos de servir
aprende a ser mujer
cuida lava plancha cocina
atiende
pero de nuestros deseos de nuestros
sueños de nuestros sentimientos jamás se
habló
como si no tuviéramos sexualidad
ambiciones y aspiraciones lejos de
encontrar el amor y depender de su éxito
por eso nos dicen que busquemos
protección
con la idea de príncipe es que nos
rescaten de peligros por eso nos llenan
de estereotipos de belleza que nos
provocan inseguridades con nuestro
cuerpo
y que nos llenan de más inseguridad al
decidirnos a hacer cargo de nuestra vida
y nuestro desarrollo
ese tiempo que dedicamos para hacer lo
que alguien más dijo que debemos es lo
que nos aleja y nos distrae de
cuestionarnos porque debemos ser lo que
alguien más dice
a todas ellas a las que ya empezaron su
lucha a las que no están seguras
y también a las que están en contra mi
único y sincero consejo es cuestiona te
lo todo mujer
porque para poder abrir los ojos no
esperes respuestas fáciles
vas a sufrir al ver y entender la
realidad
te vas a sentir sin rumbo a veces tan
sola y con tanto miedo que vas a querer
cerrar los ojos y correr a tu lugar
seguro
vas a querer ignorar la verdad y pensar
que lo que le pasa a la de enfrente
jamás te va a pasar a ti oa alguien que
amas
y por si fuera poco el golpe de realidad
a las mujeres
si nos tenemos que enfrentar en el
feminismo a posturas a comentarios
que al principio son muy incómodos pero
que después de un tiempo se vuelven tan
absurdos que simplemente dejan de
molestar
las feministas
somos machorras
las feministas somos lesbianas y por eso
odiamos a los hombres las feministas no
queremos igualdad lo que queremos es ser
hombres
las feministas somos violentas somos
descuidadas feas gordas y hasta nazis
somos
hablan desde una completa ignorancia
refuerzan sus prejuicios
y esperas en su violencia contra todo
aquello que consideran diferente
pero gracias a estas mujeres diferentes
hay avances que el día de hoy no serían
posibles si no fuera por ellas
por estas mujeres en el mundo que en
algún momento
se cuestionaron sobre su derecho a la
igualdad a la libertad y al desarrollo
todo esto que al día de hoy
damos por hecho
gracias a esta lucha de estas mujeres
por ejemplo podemos usar pantalón
podemos tener acceso a la educación
votar y ser votadas a cargos de elección
podemos trabajar y obtener un salario
podemos participar competir en temas
deportivos esto que damos por hecho fue
gracias a la lucha de miles de mujeres
en el mundo mujeres que pagaron con
lágrimas y sangre sus sueños
por cambiar el mundo
no sabemos cuánto tiempo ha pasado desde
que una mujer se preguntó
porque no tenía derechos porque tenía
que que tener cierto rol podríamos estar
hablando de siglos
a pesar del tiempo en el en la brecha
del informe global de género
se dice que se necesitan 99.7 años para
alcanzar la paridad de género en el
ámbito laboral en los cargos públicos y
privados en los cargos de elección
popular y eso que tan solo en este país
en méxico somos más somos el 52% de la
población
me han preguntado con cierta burla que
yo que gano con ser diferente con ser
feminista
y la verdad es que en este camino de
inmediato solo pierdes
perdí mi comodidad
al abrir los ojos y darme cuenta de la
realidad me ha costado muchísimo
convivir con quienes eran mi círculo
cercano empecé a platicar con ellas y
ellos y me empezaron a evitarlo
en mi familia
deje de tolerar críticas comentarios e
imposiciones de por qué trabajaba qué
necesidad tenía yo
porque me arriesgaba si nadie me lo iba
a agradecer
del egoísta que me estaba convirtiendo
al seguir mis aspiraciones y abandonar
mis obligaciones
al dejar a mis hijos e hijas sin madre
el como seguía mis caprichos
aunque haciendo un análisis más
optimista por supuesto que ganado
me liberé de mis prejuicios limitaciones
y de mi propia inseguridad
en el trabajo deje de desconfiar sobre
mis decisiones abrí los ojos y oídos
para escuchar a mujeres mujeres que al
día de hoy son fuente de inspiración
y calle las críticas con resultados y
eso para mí no tiene precio
por eso me pregunto por qué no ser
feministas
por qué no vernos como hermanas
compartirnos todo esto que nos hemos
preguntado que nos ha hecho daño y
callamos por imposición
por qué no unirnos ser cómplices y
construir juntas todos esos cambios que
son tan necesarios porque no combatir la
violencia como un problema que nos
incumbe y afecta a todas por igual
esta no es una lucha contra los hombres
luchamos por la igualdad luchamos contra
la violencia y luchamos por una sociedad
justa
esto me ha dejado el feminismo
por ahí me han dicho con cierto
desprecio que el feminismo se ha puesto
de moda yo lo único que puedo desear es
que esta moda dure por siempre y se
expanda por todo el mundo para que cada
día seamos más porque la lucha de cada
mujer
por supuesto que sirve y hace que su
entorno se transforme
quiero terminar compartiendo con ustedes
un recuerdo que hoy tomo como un déjà vú
cuando tenía 10 años en la escuela nos
pidieron que cerráramos los ojos
y que nos hicieron que pensáramos cómo
nos veíamos en un futuro
yo me vi como china la princesa guerrera
sin miedo
al frente protegiendo a mi ejército y
con la seguridad de poder cambiar mi
mundo
quien diría que al día de hoy esa imagen
podía ser realidad
porque saben
la lucha sirve
te transforma
evoluciona
y con esto claro que cambiamos el mundo
gracias